many of your projects have been in the
true crime genre
what attracts you to this well i think
my original attraction to true crime was
it was going to pay the bills because uh
it was the appetite it was the
meal that the television networks wanted
for a long time i would say half
to maybe more than half of what was on
cbs or
nbc was true crime and then when
lifetime became the
preeminent supplier they wanted true
crime so i think at the start
um it was just that was the world i was
in and that was
i had to learn and then eventually i
realized that i could become a
storyteller in that
world and i didn't have to do it the way
everyone else was doing it which was
kind of a straightforward
police narrative that there were other
ways to tell true crime and uh
so i tried to find the emotional hook
in a true crime movie and so i would
make stories that weren't as much about
the crime but
as much about the effect it had on the
people who either were
the victims or were the police
or were the criminals and how did their
lives change and what were the emotions
they were going through and
um you know we did capture the green
river killer
which tom cavanaugh was nominated for
wars and we won the dgc award
for outstanding mini-series and
that movie is about a man's crisis of
conscience of giving up on god because
for 25 years he would constantly
be finding these murdered young women
in between 15 and 25 in seattle
and he couldn't find this guy and for 25
years he chased this guy
and he was a deeply devoted christian
and at one point he just turned to god
and said you can't possibly exist
if this is what you are allowing to
happen
and you aren't letting me fix it i was
put here to find this guy and arrest him
and stop these women from dying
and that's my calling and i'm not doing
my job so where are you
so we made a movie about that in many
stories about that and i still to this
day i think it's the highest-rated
mini-series and on element and we won
all kinds of awards and
and uh and the person who wrote it wrote
agnes of god so
that was right in his wheelhouse and i
chose him because
we wanted to explore that as opposed to
what was the crime how did the girls die
how were they killed
how did they find him what was the what
were the clues
it wasn't a detective story it was an
emotional story
how do you find these stories yeah i'm
sure you you scour the news and you
look at what's on goodreads or different
things but what is it that calls to you
about a certain story
the thing that people have to remember
about all genres is
in the end do you care and is it a good
story
it doesn't matter if it's a romantic
comedy or true crime or a western
all of which i've done you still want to
find does it pull out your heartstrings
does it make you feel something to make
you feel angry does it make you feel sad
does it communicate to you a personal
experience
do you feel for the characters do you
root for the
protagonist do you root against the
antagonist those are all the things that
have to happen in a story
i remember a couple of screenwriters
early on would say to me when i started
in the true crime business well this is
what really happened
i said that doesn't matter what really
happened is
almost irrelevant if it's not a good
story if what
really happened is the excuse we have
for not being good storytellers
then we need to get another job it
really happened is not the answer to
a story flaw to not being able to have a
second act twist and not being able to
have a satisfying third act
those things still have to happen even
when you're in true crime
so of course when i could find a great
book as i did with capturing rip killer
or
establish a relationship with a great
crime writer like anne rule
who was probably the greatest crime
writer of all time may she rest in peace
uh i would say that also helped because
for instance anne i made three of her
movies she had a nose for
telling a story like nobody i knew and
uh and she again wasn't just interested
in the crime
she was interested in the characters
around the crime and that some of that
came from her own story right with it
sort of put her on the map well anne
rule's story is amazing i mean anne rule
was
uh she was a crime reporter a prime
journalist she
her brother was a cop her dad was a cop
i think her grandfather was a cop and
her uncles were cops
so she grew up in that world um she knew
she wasn't going to be a cop so she
decided to be a crime journalist and
i think she wrote under a pseudonym
because women didn't do that then
and i think when she wrote her first
book she wrote it under a pseudonym
and she was living in seattle and she
was volunteering at a
uh suicide hotline and the guy sitting
next to her was a very attractive
guy from the university of washington
was also volunteering they would show up
on the same night every week and talk
they became friends and they would go
out for coffee afterwards and
you know kind of decompress from what
i'm sure was not a fun
night and they became friends and then
one day she turns on a tv and
he's been arrested and it's ted bundy
and so
she had access to him she talked to him
after he was arrested
and she wrote the deliberate stranger i
think was the name of the book and that
put and rule on the map and i think
that's the first time i could be wrong
but it was right around the first time
she put her name her own name and rule
on a book and so she always drew from
that but i did
i did a roblo movie with her i did a
gina gershon movie with her
and both times she was still and these
were books that had been around for
10 years at least she was still in touch
with the victims families
so she called them when we were doing
the movie and say hey we're making a
movie and this is going to play your mom
or your dad or your brother or sister
and uh and then even when we when the
movie came on she called them after it
aired so yeah
she maintained those relationships
they were like her children the books
were like her children and the victims
families were like her children as well
once you find a story that you want to
then have some screenwriter adapt
what are your steps when it becomes to
the true crime genre
well with true crime uh obviously the
first thing you have to do is
break it down and come up with a an
outline and a
treatment so that's the first step with
the screenwriter is what are the story
beats you know
on a broad scale what's the beginning
middle and end um
what's the first act second act twist
and third act even if you're working in
an eight act structure for television
movies you're still in a
three-act structure so that's the first
bit is what story are we telling
because with a lot of them there's you
know it could be
a 10-year story or you could just tell a
sliver of it so you have to decide
what's the story we want to tell
and once we decide like who are we
rooting for who we rooting against
are we going to see the crimes are we
not going to see the crimes a lot of
a lot of kind of structural bones of the
story you have to figure out first
that's a lot of conversations before you
put pen to paper
and then you come up with a story
outline and then treatment
and then that has to get approved by
whoever's paying for it whether it a
network or a studio
and then you write a screenplay and then
um and
you know the first draft is the writer's
draft and that's when he gets to do
whatever he wants or she wants
um and then from that point forward now
it's you know it's
takes a village so now the network or
studio gets their votes and
i get my notes and you know if we get it
to an actor the actor gets their notes
and so at that point farm now you're
in that place of how do we get this made
and so now you're adjusting that story
in that screenplay
and then when you get ordered there's a
whole other process that you don't have
in fiction
which is you now have to go to the
arizona omissions lawyer
and go through the script page by page
line by line
period by period and make sure that what
you're telling
is true and you haven't defamed anyone
and so
there's a lawyer that forces the
screenwriter to annotate their script
page by page every single thing in it
has to be
based on something and if it's fiction
like if they say okay well there's a cop
and we know that
he was went home and figured it out at
home but there's no
we know that because the next day he
went in and made an arrest
but we don't have any actual
documentation that he went home and
figured it out
but we're going to write a scene where
he goes home and figures it out and
that's
that's the connective tissue between
when he doesn't catch the killer and he
does catch the killer
well they'll allow a certain amount of
that in your screenplay
maybe 10 20 um if the audience pays
attention
they'll know how much is fiction because
on a television movie if it says based
on a true story
it's almost completely true there's very
little fictionalization
if it says inspired by true events or
inspired by a true story that means the
insurance company
and the lawyers have said you took
too many liberties we're still going to
say true story but we're not going to
say based on we're going to say
inspired by and that allows you more
lead way
i always tried to get to based on i
liked my movies to be as close to the
truth as possible
uh perfect sisters was based on a true
story uh capture the renewable killer
was based on a true story
um so i i i always fought
to get as close to the based on moniker
as possible but
it wasn't always the case if there's a
book out
about the case are you then going to the
author
to adapt it and get their rights or do
you have to get the life story rights
of the individual or the state of
whomever
is is involved in the story so the
important thing to
remember when you're doing true crime
that's based on a book
is if you're optioning the book and you
don't have to
if you're optioning the book the book
doesn't come with any rights
so uh if you're going to do a story
about
i did this movie the grim sleeper for a
lifetime which i directed and produced
and it was based on the work of a
journalist at the la weekly a young
woman who was a fact checker and figured
out
that there was a serial killer preying
on african-american women in south
central los angeles
she figured it out she wasn't even a
journalist yet she was a fact checker
from ottawa canada
and she put the pieces together and they
let her write the piece and they
eventually caught him
because of her work and she hadn't
written a book
she had written a bunch of essays for la
weekly
i didn't need anything except her
i didn't need the la weekly articles i
didn't need the la weekly there was
no book there have been stories in the
l.a times there have been stories in the
la daily news so i had plenty of source
but i needed her
so she was the rights i had to go get so
i skipped over all the writing about the
grim sleeper and i went right to the
source and i got her rights that allowed
me to depict her
it also allowed me to have her talk to
the screenwriter and tell them
the entire story which is what she did
the screenwriter tina booth brilliant
screenwriter
spent time with christine palasek who
was the real woman and she told her her
story
so that's it's important because people
think when they buy a book or they buy a
magazine article they buy a newspaper
accounting of something
that they're getting something with that
all you're getting is the point of view
of that author
now that may be important and if they're
the sole source
then you do need it because you can't
source it from anywhere else but if it's
a big story and it's been
it's been uh recorded and reported
elsewhere in like three or four five
sources you don't need a book you don't
you don't need a magazine article you
just need but if you're going to depict
somebody as your heroine or hero
you do need their rights because you
can't really depict somebody unless
they're super famous
um without their rights you can do the
michael jackson or elvis story without
rights
but you can't do the christine palisac
story without rights i needed the
sheriff david reichert who was the
sheriff in
seattle who broke the green river killer
case i needed his rights
what what constitutes how famous someone
is because you know you could have
youtubers
some of whom could be famous to a
certain age group and then
older populations wouldn't like they
have to be famous to a level where there
has been
so much coverage of them that the
insurance company would feel like it's
impossible to defame them because they
have been in the public eye
at such a high level youtubers would not
qualify
um uh you know they have to be at the
elvis level
sure okay john f kennedy orlando
somebody who's whose whole life has been
in the public eye and there's
hundreds and hundreds of magazines and
newspapers and documentaries
then you can get i mean i think most of
the elvis and michael jackson
movies and for television and mini
series for television were done without
rights
call me the rise and fall of heidi flies
you did a movie on heidi fleiss back in
what year was that 1990s
2000 okay um
we all know what the story is about but
what about the story behind the story of
getting some of the
talent attacks so uh that's a great
story i will had made a bunch of movies
true crime movies for jeff wachtel who
was a friend and he was at the time
running the usa network which
didn't make a lot of television movies
but when they did they generally did
pretty well
and one of the things that jeff told me
is they would
routinely in their staff meetings come
up with ideas for television movies
and they would make a poster of it and
they would go to
like 10 malls in the midwest and they
would put the posters up and have people
come over and
all they would see is the title and some
image and they would say
which of these movies would you want to
see most and which would you like to see
least and
rank them and he said one
after another every time we do this the
title
that comes back the highest is the heidi
fleiss story
but we don't have a handle on it so he
said but you're
such a good storyteller would you do the
heidi fly story
and i said to him if you're thinking
cradle to grave like how did she become
heidi fleisch and what did she do and
who were her clients
i'm not interested he said was there a
story you're
you are interested in telling i said
well let me think about it
and i thought about it i thought about
it and then i woke up one morning and
i was like on a run or something then
bingo i thought of it and i called him
back and i said
if you'll let me make uh
all about eve in the world of
high-priced call girls in beverly hills
because the story of the true story is
that heidi stole the business
from the legendary madame before her who
was madame alex who had had all the
studios and all the producers and all of
them
and heidi was one of her girls and then
heidi called the cops had madame
alexander arrested for a 24-hour hold
and during that 24 hours
she stole every client and by the time
madame alex got out of prison
jail county jail in beverly hills jail
heidi had her business and how he went
from being a call girl to a madam
so i said if you let me do all about eve
because that's an interesting story
then i'm interested and he goes go ahead
and brenda fricker played madame alex
and jamie lynn siegler played and that
was pretty high-priced talent for me
brenda fricker was an academy award
winner and
jamie ziegler was on the sopranos at the
time we thought
what better than a jewish girl from long
island playing a jewish girl from
encino and it worked great
you